earlier we were talking about perception
and and people seem that you guys are
doing great you're raising money you're
having your film and several festivals
but sometimes it looks a lot easier that
it really is how hard is making a film I
mean people think they'll just get it
out there and it's really easy yes no
problem everyone should do it um it is
hard it's really hard um you want to
take this one yeah we work like 14 15 16
hours a day seven days a week and
sometimes it feels like you're really
not getting anywhere well each one of
those festivals you had to pay in a
mission for a submission fee of course
you had to research it and see if it was
one you wanted to go to and submit to
then you had to pay the submission fee
if you lucky you got in and then you
have to buy a plane ticket or pay for
gas to drive there and you have to
replace your hotel sometimes they put
you up sometimes and fly you out
sometimes they don't a lot of them don't
have it in the budget um they're just
people who like movies and are trying to
make something cool so they don't have
the money to fly you in so there's that
and then movies themselves are expensive
and hard you're under you know you're
under a time crunch we shot our movie in
16 days with two days off shooting 10 to
13 pages a day which is that not good ah
not enough time and so and there's an
extreme amount of stress because you've
got that's that's your window you had we
had as much time to write the movie and
prepare and then as much time to finish
as possible but that if you don't get it
in the camera then you don't you don't
have it and and nobody else cares I mean
they care they want you to do well and
but nobody cares like you care so if
you're not doing it it's not going to
get done and um things can be lost hard
drives can fail that have all of your
footage on it and you
spent hundreds of thousands of dollars
on a movie that is now gone they can get
accidentally shipped to Germany without
your knowledge you know did this happen
yeah I was wondering where this joke we
were ya say we put this we were dealing
with we made a deal with the
post-production house that ended up
being a post-production apartment that
they weren't exactly what they said they
were supposed to be my last about six
months we lost six months of working
with they were either negligent or just
flat-out lying yeah so anyways it was it
was a kind of an ugly situation and so
be careful about who you who you trust
mm-hmm because it's hard because as
actors again we're so used to working
for free or working for credit or copy
meals and things like that and you know
technical people aren't willing to do
that generally so when you find someone
who is either they're amazing or there's
something wrong with them what you think
if someone has their name on something
that you take care take care but that's
not always the case no one's ever gonna
care as much as you and just because you
have the value of if I agree to do
something I'm going to do it well and
complete it doesn't mean that everyone
else thinks that it feels that way too
so again no one cares like you care and
you yeah it's not finding your team yeah
building your team and we met a lot of
people on this one that we want to work
with for the rest of our career like
Clint Eastwood has this you know amazing
crude that he uses again and again and
again and it's easy and fun and they're
also used to working together and that's
I think every filmmakers doing this to
find that crew that it's perfect just
make a short film or web series start
building your crew before you commit to
a but you know some people don't have
the means to do that so um it's hard
well like our editor Chad reserve is a
good friend of ours but he's also
someone who I I know that he's funny so
I trust his his judgment and he's
what he does and he's fast and he's fun
to be around and those are all things
that are really important so we're maybe
I should have said his name I don't want
anyone else i know who he is you should
good you know yes good we don't use them
all the time you can't afford you the
right
you